bonjour à tous alors je suis de retour
pour la ronde de de speechless féminin
donc là ils en sont la première partie
donc c'est cette fois le match c'est de
caterina l'anneau contre valentina
gouina donc on va regarder ça avec
voodoo beaucoup d'intérêt je pense que
ça va être des parties très très
intéressante donc comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe
je semble l'échiquier et voilà c'est
donc cette partie là et je dirais que
grâce à la paire de fou et elle serait
peut-être moi et mes bons j'allais dire
elle peut être en faveur de caterina
mais c'est vrai que ce cavalier un gars
très forte qui peut venir en b 4 faire
des menaces sur ces 2 est aussi c'est
vrai que les noirs semblent avoir un peu
davantage d'espacé donc je pense que la
paire de fou ça n'a pas trop d'intérêt
ici parce que là le développement est
vraiment très mauvais pour une folle et
blanc donc ici donc faux calculs et 6
passes sur ces trois donc ces trois
cavaliers ces deux sur la prise en d4
on va prendre mon tour donc donc ça
devrait aller quand même mais faut quand
même faire attention
après ça règle le cas vahid arrive à
ressortir par celle de donc s'avère d'un
salaire de pas bordeaux soucis au pire à
part des trois disons que si le fou vent
c'est qu'à faire payer en b3 pour
essayer de l'empêcher le real a sorti
toujours forte hier par détroit dans
tous les cas ça bonjour jérémy et oui
c'est pas qu'ils vivent aujourd'hui you
otto dix alors non qu'elle réfléchit
beaucoup il lui reste que deux minutes
donc on dirait que bon il vaudrait mieux
qu'elle fasse ces trois je pense voilà
donc elle l'a fait mais avec un peu de
retard donc mais toujours deux c'est
peut-être possible mais ouais mais bon
je pense max kamali serait il sera
bloqué tu penses pas qu'il sera enfermée
même après la prise après plus en d4
soit à chaque fois qu'on essaiera de
faire b3 on ouvrirait la diagonale du
fou qui arrive qui arrivera à défendre
le cavalier donc je pense que ce cabinet
n'a pas n'a pas mangeable
mais ça n'était pas clair disant sûr fou
prend des quatre on peut faire tour d2
et après peut-être passé le fouet et 6 2
essayer de choper ce cavalli mais ça va
être vraiment très difficile ça est très
compliqué parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
essaie de faire des tours d2 le cas
autour des ans le cavalier sortir à
chaque fois par ses deux donc autour des
8 je pense que sa robe en cours pour
essayer de prendre le pion et à prévenir
en dix ans peut-être
c'est l'air vraiment pas mal donc là je
pense le seul coup ça fait un truc comme
vous j'ai cinq peut-être vous essayez de
taper le cul ont aussi eu 7
mais bon c'est pas clair passer là du
coup y aura fou et si je pense on sera
obligé de prendre et après il y aura des
tours d2 mais à la fin il y aura peut
être cinq
tant que le roi soit pas menacée si le
royaume 9,6 fait ça ne marche pas parce
qu'on prend et après assuré cheikh est
après on prend la tour donc voilà donc
ça c'est pas que c'est pas clair du tout
mais là je pense que vous faisiez 5
c'est nécessaire
donc ouais parce qu'en fou comme b3 y
aura sur faut prendre des cafés après le
cavalier allez va en sortir savais pas
ça aide pas beaucoup
donc là je pense qu'il faut vraiment à
tout prix l'échangé de matériel pour
éviter justement les menaces au kef où
j'ai cinq seuls coureurs que je pensais
enfouie 6 peut-être six tours 17
c'est pas très réactif disons qu'on peut
faire des coups comme tout un peut-être
essayer de sortir le fourneau f4 on sait
capable et pousse à fait en échec à
après peut-être qu'on peut retrouver
l'adn menace on peut faire des menaces
comme fou aussi et peut-être donc là
donc là peut-être même tour
après sortir le fou mais bon c'est un
peu embêtant parce que tu as essayé de
sa attaquera la tour donc on pourra pas
vraiment faire des menaces vu que on
sera obligé de vous de la tour et après
le plan solaire
donc c'est pas si simple peut-être le
mieux c'est juste ou là donc elle donne
le pion donc faut prendre des cartes yal
mais ça devrait aller je pense qu'elle
peut faire des tours d2 et après sortir
le fond dans ces quatre cas mais ça
devra t'on plat et l'essayer j'imagine
de mettre son voilà peut-être même faire
des âges car trimestre le fonds en h36
ai jamais fait mais elle peut cela si
elle a le temps
3 qu'est hk donc elle voulait juste
aider un peu sa structure ou alors
peut-être faire foi je crois imagine
fois je crois c'était son plan mais ou
alors elle voulait juste défendre le
faut peut-être
ok vous les bafouez ok donc là c'est pas
parce que pour eux un échange les tours
mais mais bon ce n'est pas nécessaire
pour les norns le paf
ouais elle a choisi de ne pas le faire
et on pousse après on fait en fait de
ces cinq peut-être
alors
bon là je pense qu'il y avait davantage
blancpain m ouais ça a l'air vraiment
très très difficile à jouer ça donc sur
la prise il ya peut-être retour cet
après des fous des fous des 5 c'est
vraiment difficile ça pour les non il ya
des tours julien ça marche jamais parce
qu'à chaque fois il y aura droit à trois
après le roi bien bien en dessin qui
peut-être en tout temps
les 200 commence à être mal autant
peut-être que le temps sera un facteur
décisif
qui sait
ça va être compliqué quand même pour le
nord est fougueux car c'était possible
aussi pour empêcher le cahier de sortir
peut-être mais bon c'est pas nécessaire
parce que ça sera ma travailleuses a été
élu 8e
bon bah du coup bien joué bien vu
caterina donc elle a gagné la première
partie donc ça s'annonce bien pour elle
donc là et la ligne noire cette fois bon
moyen pour ce qu'il se passera
donc apparemment kadhafi katerina c'est
une star de thiès comme aux français je
vois avec même sur mon propre ces
émeutes
donc faut qu'elles gagnent là on l'a ses
portes alors la soutient vous avez plus
tôt
du coup ça c'est une star indienne ouais
on peut pas si classique donc les coups
c'était fou de après foule 3 donc les
blancs n'ont pas de chercher un système
vraiment très agressive donc à y aller
par 2 ed4 c'était juste plutôt cosy
sauna
duke ou qu'est ce qui se passe là alors
fou que trois j'aime bien il ya
peut-être des menaces sur l'île d'amour
ou alors on peut peut-être poussé le
pousser le client c'est possible ou
alors même par des fous à chis seller
pas mal à ça a l'air assez simple à
jouer mais c'est vrai qu'il nord ils ont
aussi eu quelques menaces avec elle et
ses 4 way car il ya pas mal de qualités
4 et la fois ci c'est juste pas ce qui
se passera si vous prendre un point le
rapt end et db4 aussi qui peut m'arriver
b 4e ce salaire faut juste faire gaffe
aux pions à 6 mais je pense que ça peut
se tenter suivies d'oedèmes d'un v6
peut-être
au fait du coup dit moi aussi le stream
est bien fluide sept mois parce que hier
j'ai c'était c'était un peu un cauchemar
donc avec ma connexion internet donc
dites moi s'il ya s'il ya des bugs et
salades
s'il ya des preuves non dites moi je
sais pas si tout va bien j'espère que ça
va a priori ça doit être réglée donc
voilà j'espère
du coup là là j'aime bien et menaces
avec bekaert peut-être ou alors
qu'avaient ces cas comme j'ai dis
peut-être aussi on peut doubler les
tours sur la commune s'est dans certains
cas où aussi enfin non poussé est sain
que j'allais dire mais non ça ça devait
être un très long parce que y'aura être
capable d'être et après on n'a pas trop
envie d'ouvrir cette diagonale
donc ouais plutôt se concentrer sur le
net on est mort
donc je dirais que initiative et et
certainement pour les deux mois
maintenant
en plus le pion f2 est attaqué donc là
il ya peut-être des bécasses suivi de
tours c3 ok aussi d'am-dam c'est sain
c'est pas mal elles peuvent être
échangés les aventis et d'entraîneurs en
une alors assez avantageuse pour les no
way parce que là les change de teinte à
pourrait bien se passer pour elle ouais
c'est ce qu'elle appelle
alors là donc j'ai l'impression que ça
aide un peu les blancs d'abord jouer ce
coup deux tours c'est simple parce que
c'est j'ai à présent c'est un peu une
perte de temps ça va pas vraiment d'idée
donc ça alors edith autres ils pouvaient
faire f 4 ont commencé à pousser les
pions
je passe deux tours c'est simple fait
d'être poussés ouais mais bon y'a pas
y'a pas grand chose à faire non plus bon
c'est vrai il n'y a pas eu grand chose à
faire donc ouais
du coup c'est pas si ça ne plaît le
point noir réside peut-être maintenant
faire des dames clients mais bon même ça
ça change pas grand chose
ça aide pas grand chose je sors d'un
sillon rassurant tour deux ans après da
sur des riffs 4 y aura g3 est la dame
peut même se faire enfermer d'ailleurs
c'est fait pas gaffe sur dame sain qu'il
y aurait peut-être f4 suivi des quatre
ça sera ça sera difficile
ah oui il ya toujours les vagues on ça
du coup je sais pas trop quelle école
footing est ce que c'est une blague ou
serait ce d'ailleurs puisque aussi à
tracer c'est juste une blague et que tu
veux juste me faire peur
de quoi ils sont rentrés dans son final
maintenant donc si lyall échange de
dames
je sais pas je dirais presque cdc en
faveur des des blancs parce que l'orgue
cavaillé assez fort ouais donc elle a
choisi de ne pas le faire donc ça
confirme ce que je disais ça lui était
archi ça va très bien et toi
ok donc la tête détournée de danse un
tacle plus le pion à être pas si simple
à jouer il faut mais c'est vrai que le
pull le plus on ne peut pas être unis
est prenable parce que quand le fou ne
sera plus un prise y aura toujours des
tours d2 donc là le fou tout ce qu'il a
à faire c'est de revenir à la maison et
après surtout pas envie à tours 2-2 ou
alors si on vend même si faire tout voir
et un donc catherine à faire ça
ah mince alors bon donc est-ce que c'est
pierre qui est rond le foot ça va est ce
que c'est quand même un regard d'âge où
c'est vraiment horrible c'était le prime
de windows
bref voilà ok donc ça veut vraiment gay
mois bon bah désolé désolé je te j'ai
tenté encore une fois parce que je
pensais qu'il essayait il s'était juste
en première qui a eu le way mais du coup
c'est pas sur mon livre c'est juste que
je peux pas vous faire de ce crime
apparent on ordi aime pas mvr alors je
sais pas il doit être je pense que sur
la chaîne 2 litres ims il va le faire
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il peut être là
ou alors tu t'es que c'est la journée
d'eurocoupe
je ne sais pas faudra voir à il a déjà
fini il a déjà fini au hockey
ok dans cette mission est super fermé
mais je pense que c'est à l'avantagé des
blancs parce que du coup elle a juste à
faire tout ce qu'elle a à faire c'est de
prendre le pion mais après deux passes
et ambiguïté après de faire maths points
et schwyz qui écrivent une grosse menace
donc les doigts ont vraiment besoin de
partir avec le roi mais ça va être ça va
être vraiment mauvais quoi qu'il arrive
ce dans tous les cas il y aura des tours
8 tours 7
ça va être celle quand même très vite
rédigée son nom voilà donc la donc la
scène il est plus probable puisque du
coup il y avait des menaces avec tours
d2 et tout rejet de cet incroyable des
menaces de tous les côtés donc assez
bien défendu et la boulaye que prendre
assez facilement
ouais elle a pris après et après une
fouille way to b 8 là ça ça gagne
clairement après qu'avait ie6 est
toujours en fuite
sony n'a pas de façon directe à 102
photo b c'est vrai je commence deux
points de ce match
dommage pour katerina mais du coup bien
jouer directement
donc la cime caron calme alors qu'est-ce
qui est ce pas ce sens
aa 3 pas ok c'est à ce moment pour
empêcher un fou mais pêché faux b4 donc
là bien sûr elle défend champions c'est
pour ça qu'elle prend pas aux directeurs
des deux champions et après elle prend
donc là c'est pas dessus pas si simple
le troyen plein pour les blondes parce
que ça c'est ça un peu faible il faut
peut-être pousser ses calmes et du coup
ça se sera faible
si on pousse des seins bien sûr la caste
des 5 sera très mal donc c'est pas très
sain je pense que le mieux c'est juste
de sortir le fou mais mais bon c'est pas
du rêve la position des morts lentement
la provision des noirs par contre est
pas mal tiré avec le fou qui est met en
place et il ya peut-être des
possibilités faire 2 1 donc même si les
blancs la paire de fous je pense que ça
aide pas beaucoup ici mais du coup là
elle a trouvé un bon plan mais elle
réussit à faire dame b3 pour sortir le
fond angers 5 ce qui est pas mal donc ça
c'est quand même une grosse amélioration
comparé ce qu'elle avait donc bien joué
et ouais bien joué donc d'abord la
défend depuis en d4 et après l'été
dernier passait la dame donc ça c'est
vraiment une belle banane sommes donc là
je me demande s'il aurait pas pu faire
des foulées simple peut-être foule g5y
se passer quoi là dessus on se bat du
coup je peux mais je fais je peux parler
qu'au foot et du coup je peux pas
analyser ce qui se passait là dessus
voyons voilà donc wildcats à menacerait
change telle qu'on peut prendre mais
après faire faire des têtes des c3 et
après essayer de faire retour trop là et
après passe le tour seulement bien sûr
se prend le second n'est pas prenable à
cause de la touvre
ouais donc bien sûr la sicile et noir
prennent ça sera assez mauvais pour eux
soit tout simplement apprendre et après
on va faire ses 3 et 4 donc c'est assis
une bonne chose je dirais un apparent
d'abord ce centre là pour les plombs
donc la c3 suivi de g4 salaires pas mal
aussi
carte mais quatre j'aime pas enfin en
fait j'ai un peu changé d'avis parce que
du coup ça se placera 15 as établie
tu auras des jeux simples ou dc zinc
donc oui j'ai 4 est la bienvenue
elle a trouvé un way ont suivi de ça et
après peut-être pousser les pions
donc là les normes clairement poussé au
oui il n'y a pas trop de façon de
l'empêcher s'ils veulent pousser les
cinq à la haine raciale à elle réussira
à le faire valentino donc mais bon c'est
pas entrer au souci donc à la pas
forcément voulu faire un site est elle
facile de faire je pensais que vu que la
vf riec les cavaliers ça veut dire que
voulait pas prendre avec une gamine du
coup elle prendra simplement être la
tour et ça c'est encore mieux poil et ça
allait pas mal pour pour banny n'a
maintenant peut-être quelques soucis le
café après essayer de faire des
caillasses cinq cobayes dessin en plus
dépendants de notre que l'adversaire
joue
donc vous êtes tous des fans de quartier
alors du coup faut espérer qu'ils
avaient réussi à sauver sa donc la saga
c'est compliqué pour elles figurent dès
le 4 ou l'ordi trouve cette fois c'est
lui mettre la pression peut-être dans
certains cas rossi quasiment du coup
elle revient de leur gain de 6 voulue
rapac et si je pense du coup je pense
qu'elle voulait juste ouvrir la couvrir
la colonne ou alors vous de mettre son
cahier la bonne idée sur b3 je pense
qu'il y aura des cahiers des 5
du coup b3 ce sera encore pire parce que
ça serait assez affaiblissant et après
quel dessein a qu'à prendre peut faire
décaler ya six aussi à prendre en
décapant des quatre titres ça a l'air
pas mal
donc là faut vraiment défendre ce plan b
2 donc la tour e 2c baussillon après sûr
qu'elle et ses 4 malgré ses quatre
essais de faire des sourds en finale
pour défendre ce option un peu trop vous
essayez de l2 tenir
donc elle a choisi de pousser les pions
dans quelques contre attaques ou là
c'est vraiment un sens il lui reste
quatre minutes un valentinois je viens
de regarder et cathy ekaterina us 20
secondes c'est incroyable la différence
regardez ça incroyable où la wii donc ça
change beaucoup la donne sa vie non
c'est difficile ah oui bah dis donc
avec douze secondes là surtout dans une
coalition qui est pas qui est pas top
ça va être ça va être compliqué elle est
surtout là le puits mamba tomber
peut-être il ya des fossés 8 pour
essayer de sauver un peu de faire des
fouilles et s'est attelé à s'y essayer
de pousser le camp peut-être ou alors là
ils essaient de d'empêcher le cahier de
sortir la foulée icaze ne sent plus ne
sont plus libres donc le cavalier ne
fait plus ne peut plus y aller ouais
c'est l'excès de celui-ci il y aura il y
aura roi des singes
après accueilli ces quatre le pion de
pousser peut plonger
bon c'est pas du rêve ouais
mais il se bat elle se bat lui trop beau
c'est bien mais combative donc c'est
vrai qu'elle peut essayer de stopper ce
qu elle peut essayer mais dans ce cas là
il y aurait peut-être eu rouaissi suivi
de cavaye e3 ou alors peut-être des
idées sur son pion à trois longueurs
dans tous les cas c'est un
ça sera difficile de sauver ceux qui ont
peut-être aussi b5 les noirs peuvent
aussi ouais mais bon ça sert pas à grand
chose et d'échanger des cures en vaut
mieux les garder et essayer de choper
l'époux de faire des cavaliers payant
mais ça du coup c'est fait pas gaffe
pièce le cavaly sera isra renfermer sur
calais b ont peut-être eu un cas celui
de roi qu'il revient ainsi c'est
possible que ça que ça sorte que quel
soit revenir à partir du foulard ça
tourne ça tourne peut-être que ça fait
un bon sens
et a vraiment trouvé des bons coups
surtout avec heures avec trois mandats à
la pendule c'est incroyable donc là je
dirais que c'est déjà pas si clair parce
que le cavaly il a des problèmes qu'ils
vivent b2 il sera il se fera encore
chassé par le roi civ en f2 il s'agit
dans tous les cas il sera chassé euro
avril
voilà donc c'est pas si simple c'est
vraiment pas ça tu y as trouve cette
même nul ouais non c6 et c7 est vraiment
nul en fait parce que roy cavalli un bep
2 3 c3 qui avait ya quatre bras b 4
leroy cieux cavaliers bessin et d'après
lui poser du nord sont donc j'ai de
sacrifier encore pour essayer d'empêcher
la nulle donc là je pense que va fermer
cinq bien sûr ça le seul moyen de
continuer si un remuant b2 bien sûr le
roi continuera en c3 donc la b5 suivi de
peut-être cahier b6 pour regarder un peu
initiative à mon avis ça sera une seul
moyen de continuer ils sont quoi parce
que la prise reprise c'est clairement
pas bien un peu ce roi prendre donc ça
donnerait un peu des chances même des
chansons boudreau excuses y aura
peut-être des craintes étaient des rois
à 6,8 de voir prend à cette donc voilà
on sait jamais tout peut arriver a donc
elle a fait mieux auj
elle avait pour la nulle
[Musique]
ouais mais réfléchit encore donc ta
cavale y en a deux en fait quelques
aveux les 1er 2e marié rien rien à faire
on rêve de ce roi de trois élevages
juste faire un terme au cavalier
donc il vaut mieux qu'elle fasse nul ici
ouais ça sera fait une plaque a essayé
de tenter vainement sa perf est ok donc
on part tout en moins cinq partout pour
chaque ligne
donc voilà c'est la même qu'on avait vu
avant avec
le fougueux deux défauts et 3 à saint pé
i fé rock'n ouais ça a changé ça me
change il n'y avait pas que le fossé sa
précédente
je crois que si on leur a pas mieux
donc là peut-être je dirais peut-être
dbk de ses 5
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait donc la
wii nord clairement ils veulent à
attaquer à l'est le froid et qui aura
des clio 4 pour empêcher vous pouvez des
trois peut-être voire même fou sur cette
diagonale ou même ses cinq en fait ces
cinq salles art hop tu es fou g4 aussi
pour essayer de créer des petites
menaces c'est ça je me demande vraiment
s'il se passe là dessus ça a l'air de
dayton papa de ce 5
voilà c'est ce qu'elle fut donc la
bourse appareils moins donc on verra ce
qui se passe c'est la troupe s'est un
peu trop tôt mais on verra ça à l'air
d'être bien peut-être qu'à des cahiers
des quatre vous pêchez ça hassan tué à
celle du couac à trois je pense
nécessaire mais sur l'afrique du coup la
couronne à suhr noël feront d'abord il a
appris l'attaqué va essayer de toucher
105 pb 5
ou alors t'as qu'à eux mêmes prendre et
après faire des a4 et essayer de mets
très apprécié en son saut pion qui sera
arriérés en baisse
takm apprendre à 5 heures il poussé à 4
faire des tours b en déca viv savent
peut-être même d'un bébé 3 sat est
possible donc ça a l'air pas mal pour
les banques mais les nord aussi ont dû
contre jeu à la halle aux grains de sel
arrive à pousser h 5 h 4 ça peut être
vraiment très dangereux avec avec des
quatre aussi dans certains cas donc
gagné un tacle de tous les côtés par la
qualité qantas à leur salaire faire un
pôle nord ouais c'est ce qu'il a joué ok
donc être suivie 2h 5h 4 mais il faut
faire gaffe à ce qui inverse où la
dagger on ça elle a gaffé donc katrina
et voilà les gagnantes
je dirais c'est assez facile et on peut
être parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de deux pièces qui sont assez active
mais quand même cédé c'est bien pour les
voir ça donc h 5 h cas c'est possible
peut-être pour leur détailler cet ours
est vite peut-être oui mesdames c'est ça
tu auras toujours siens faut en général
faut éviter de mettre la dame sur la
même main la même colonne que la tour
voilà donc là c'est ce qu'elle a fait
voter mais du coup il y aura peut-être
tour siens
ok a choisi ça
donc là faut dire qu'il ya aussi le pion
g5y en leur mais je sais pas si c'est
impossible de prendre beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup précédant leur là de prendre en
jeu 5 mai et non du coup il y avait le
cas peut-être mais tous et un salaire de
tenir tacot joue quelque chose d'un des
normes donc sur ça ouais si la trouve je
joue juste quelque chose de fait qui est
gigantesque nappe et du cou replacements
la partie donc
damas 7
aulas pour tous réfutent à la dangereuse
avec ayew est roi il arrive aussi donc
cathérine vraiment aux avantages ici je
pense acheter impossible c'est
intéressant ce village 4 c'est peut-être
défaut à six par exemple chaos watts est
une franchise c'est peut-être possible
ou alors juste tour et fait donc là faut
quand même faire un peu gaffe parce que
le fouet sur la même diagonale cola tour
donc si jamais le cavaly bouge y aura
peut-être des des soucis avec un plateau
le stream dagon corps bahamas alors ben
désolé
j'espère que j'espère que ça va quand
même pas que ces câbles puisque du coup
je sais pas quoi un conte avec gaza
j'avais même souci hier et je pensais
qu'aujourd'hui ça ça serait réglé parce
que d'habitude ma connexion internet ça
va mais apparemment on nordine un palais
stream a une image fixe donc c'est tout
tous les coins et boyle a ou c ou c
juste l'échiquier par exemple juste une
image bois ou les diffusent monde sauf
moi j'espère que ça ira bientôt
du coup alors sa venue chez tout le
monde de hockey en tableaux ok donc
j'espère c'est une belle peinture au
fond
alors bon ouais j'espère que j'espère
que ça marche
c'est à ce que ça c'est juste être
ben je regarde le chat en fait mais il
ya un gros délire en fait entre le
moment que là que je vois les enfin que
vous voyez ce que mémé réaction aux
commandes
je pense qu'il doit y avoir au moins
cinq minutes de délai entre entre eux
entre le moment où vos les commentaires
vous voyez mais ma réponse
donc oui je regarde la gg j'avais déjà
se rendre sur mon portable donc je
regarde mais du coup ok donc là il ya
peut-être des fouets 3 parce que
lecavalier ça rend les blacks à ce géant
du coup il ya peut-être ya peut-être sa
foi si c'était possible suivi de fou
prend 1,4 ça m'avait lavera pas mal
d'heures province faut acheter celui de
l'om n'en doutais qu'il y aurait eu des
problèmes allaient droit
c'est le pc op donc c'est mon pc qui
veut pas à qui veut pas que le stream
ok tout l'écran est toujours fixé est
toujours figé c'est vrai ya pas de
charge je pense pas que vous pouvez
désactiver malheureusement à loos le
monde donc c'est quoi le mode c'était sa
troupe qui me parle du duomo dans le
chat ou alors que je les trouve le seo
du stream ou là ouais c'est la misère
ok ok donc je pense qu'il faut que je
coure besoin comme ça vous verrez plus
ils oublient les joueuses mais au moins
au moins ça moi je repars peut-être un
peu mieux donc j'ai essayé comme ça va
assez la pose d'ailleurs je pense pas
s'ils viennent d'arrêter la partie donc
ça doit être la pause donc dites moi si
ça va mieux comme ça parce que j'ai du
coup j'ai de coubisou et il ya que moi
là
c'est l'exercice pour les parties à
l'aveuglé fait exact je vous fais bosser
comme ça peut-être en train de
calligraphie quoi c'est possible
c'est possible mais c'est vraiment
bizarre parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
stream sur cette offensive cet ordi et
guillaume guéraud ci a fait des stream
donc il y avait jamais eu de souci je
sais pas ce qui se passe je ne sais pas
trop ce qui se passe peut-être que je
peux changer de ce truc là
si elle trouve ses emprunts avec mon
robinet faudrait que je regarde la ouais
je jure que je vais essayer de changer
un truc du coup c'est la pose d'ailleurs
parce que là du coup voix ouais vous ne
loupez rien bon je sais de faire des
trucs là
mon dites moi si ça a changé des trucs
là je vais essayer de jeu changent mais
je me connais pas trop donc voilà donc
ça se trouve je fais n'importe quoi
peut-être que là ça a changé des trucs
dit moi aussi si c'est mieux maintenant
a priori ça doit être
j'ai enlevé fin j'ai réduit les allées à
des fps vous pouvez vu que du coup quoi
qu'il arrive vous voyez quasiment pas de
fps moment on ordonne n'essaye pas de de
le fermer 1 2 dans envoyé 3 j'espère que
c'est réglé
de toute façon l'avons ok rien comme dit
c'est la pause donc
donc on peut essayer de régler ça en
attendant que qui reprennent la partie
au savon noir jeu super à quel moment
c'est quand c'est quand j'ai coupé douce
et quand je me suis mis à tout seul là
c'est fluide au super super ok j'espère
que bah du coup parce que j'ai aussi
changé d des paramètres depuis donc ok
sens du mot ok ok ok donc s'est adjoint
le problème donc j'espère qu'après j'ai
changé des paramètres ya du coup je vois
les messages ans avec en gros d'élèves
j'espère que entre-temps j'ai pas tout
fait foirer
j'espère que ça marche encore mais bon
dieu pousser la pause donc on attend
où l'attend la priori je pense dans
quelques minutes qui me relancer
c'est à ce moment qu'une dites moi dans
ma tête ça mange encore du coup juste
pour pour vous dire pour effectivement
d'arriver au smic n'ont pas trop suivi
hier
ouais ça c'est des appariements ça les a
par exemple où on est à la 2ème donc ir
c'était le match de lundi contre baby
sahara et donc baby sahara gagner et là
c'est sûr c'est catherine valentin donc
ya pas match à 7 ans jusqu'aux au milieu
de 2 juillet le probablement début de
juillet mme beaucoup de beaucoup
beaucoup de parties voilà donc
maintenant que vous savez un peu on
repasse donc j'espère qu'ils vont
commencer bientôt
ah c'est beaucoup mieux super passe le
plaisir du coup j'espère que ça restera
comme ça
du coup j'ai peut-être où est la clé du
succès sur le sirop vias
sont toujours pas remplies ce four
bon du coup je vais juste m m la pub en
attendant que ça reprenne et je serai de
retour bientôt
[Musique]
ok alors il vient de reprendre et voilà
donc cynthia rock and donc c'est un peu
dommage pour maladie n'a d'ailleurs pas
ce que parce que la partie précédente
enfin ils ont annulé la partie mais elle
avait déjà joué la can du coup elle
avait déjà montré à son adversaire ce
qu'elle voulait jouer donc le l'élément
de surprise est un peu parti donc
j'imagine que cathy rénale hull un peu
le temps de réfléchir à ce qu'elle
voulait faire là dessus bonjour françois
à non il n'y a pas beaucoup de français
c'est vrai il y en a pas du tout
d'ailleurs à napanee n'a pas du tout
mais kateri elle parle français je crois
par la cdu en français donc on peut la
considérer comme fait comme française
ok donc ya peut-être des idées sur le
pion ces deux questions décalées kébé 4
voilà en fait ouais ce qu'elle a fait
avec quidam match car depuis 2006 pour
punta questions sur le pion h 2 là je
pense que même si ça peut être un bon
coup parce que sur cavaye f3 y aura
dommage 5 et peut-être foule g4 qui
suivra
donc comme dit qu'elle valium
ouais donc la menace non ça sera
peut-être de faire [ __ ] g4 pour
essayer de manger qu'à veiller à près de
manger h 2
peut-être aussi tour 8,7 possible pour
là je serai à huit c'est possible pour
défendre le pion aux 6 avant de faire
faute g4 tacos mc2 mais maintenu parce
que si on fait faux le gars c'est vrai
que si jamais on prend ça avec le pion
et fils se rassure un peu
un peu mal mais bon je pense que la
menace de massa sera prêt ça c'est un
peu plus grave que de perdre le flux en
lice donc alors je crois qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui va se faire bannir la même
si jamais il ya déjà des modeuses nachat
beaucoup et vous pouvez les bas niveaux
celui qui parle qui parlent anglais là
sinon je vais d'abord le faire moi même
ça c'est un pan de temps donc là
qui
ok bah du coup c'est fait c'est fait
voilà donc donc alors ici peut-être on
va prendre en f 5 mais du coup ça ouvre
la colonne elle salua lynch à la switch
ça fait longtemps on a fait ce qu'on a
fait j'espère vous allez bien alaba du
coup il faut que je me retourne je
remercie parce que le mode c'était moi
même qui a fait ça
bon du coup cette fausse et g5 suivi des
cartes c'est peut-être possible un
simple pot 6 intéressant pour ouvrir le
centre
mais du coup c'est pas ma chère alors je
peux pas mettre désolé désolé je peux
pas je veux pas mettre au modérateur
désolé parce que ben c'est pas ma chaîne
du coup j'ai du coup j'ai pas vraiment
le contrôle de ce genre de chose si
c'était ma chaîne je le ferais bon 10
mai mais le pas à bord de bus de soucis
voilà donc où la salers gros avantage
pour les noirs ça avec que dame c'est
peut-être ça regarde salaire très
compliqué
donc là il y aura peut-être des bottes
1,3 après surprise cavaliers cavaliers
f4 ou alors d'un monde attendent des
gestes simples ou alors même d'un
message vidéo d'un match deux oueds un
mois sans que ça a l'air super x
kate et sam ongeri catway c'était ça
l'idée c'était sa vie j'imagine que vous
voulez venir là mais elle était un peu
trop tard
donc là il ya des menaces comme d'un
médecin est peut-être vrai mais aussi
d'amener ici suivi 2 h 6 pour enfermer
le cavalier c'est peut être possible
aussi donc ça va quand même assez
récemment mal pour les banques
au match et n'ont généré que c'est mon
nom c'est à ces silos cernon j'avais une
chaîne twitch mais là dans ce moment je
fais pas trop traîné mais j'en faisais
et j'en faisais surtout en anglais en
fait donc si vous parlez pas anglais
c'est pas très intéressant pour vous du
coup je sais mon c'est mes premiers
ciments français ça hier et aujourd'hui
je vous vois je mets à when you could à
la jack ou je commence à lui faire un
peu plus en français mais mes yeux je
veux pas donner de faux espoirs
donc c'est pour ça que je ne vais pas du
tout depuis beau match et n'a en général
est quasiment tous mes soins joseph et
en anglais pas moche
ah oui ma chaîne et marc hé oui
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir c'est juste
au dessus de ma recette de ma tête c'est
juste en haut
alors tout est relatif donc je bois je
pense que pour comparer à kasparov ou
alors que personne je pense que je n'ai
pas très forte
donc voilà ça c'est tout est relatif
ouais merci pour avoir donné le lien
wins sa machine donc là et blanc ont
réussi à survivre un peu en échange vous
mesdames mais bon c'est quand même
difficile avec avec un pion de demain je
pense que ça va ça va être assez décisif
peut être acheté cela suivi de calais
prend h 30
actuellement 90 chaînes qui demande de
quelques hélicos qu'elle paye et je suis
je pense que vu la langue que je parle
je pense que c'est assez clair mais bon
si ça se trouve il n'a jamais entendu le
français avons donc bon peut-être qu'il
ne connaît pas c'est ce pays
d'ailleurs je peux commenter en fait si
vous voulez ça c'est ma chaîne lui
commenté d'un chat avec la je suis en
face au chili lé que mental avec avec ça
voilà ça c'est ça c'est ma chaîne qui
vient commenter dans la délicate
je commande sur mon propre stream c'est
un peu un peu narcissique mais bon du
coup là on peut emmener le le roi l'a
peut-être après essayer de stopper pions
mais le roi noir est vraiment dans les
idées il ya assez de temps pour le faire
surtout là il peut pousser ses cinq
possibles un peu de procès de saint
caprais prendre prendre en d6 ouais
voilà sept ans pour faire
donc là on n'y croit pas trop voilà dans
la faille y sont blanches sont
malheureusement
peut-être peut-être rouages et 6 ouais
ce pion il arrivera jamais à le prendre
sera possible sera toujours d'étranges
épreuve et même si à pattes rouges et
royaux rares vivra cavaillé pranger set
et ça sera quand même fini à cause du
pion h qui tombe donc sympa la salle m
haget 5 lapointe finale bon bien joué
valentina du coup je regarde tout de
suite je reviens tout de suite je vaux
mais lyon n'a pu prendre un tendon
ça y est je suis de retour bon vous avez
pas louper les branches chose parce que
c'est encore l'ouverture
donc là c'est une position assez fermé
il avait que la carte ici ce qui est
faible pour une norme nature à des
cahiers des cartes qu'elle et ses six
donc certainement aussi comment comme
d'habitude ça assez y est souvent mais
c'est une variante un peu différente
donc là peut-être elle veut faire
cailler des cas suivis des guerriers si
si je pense être aussi doubler les tours
faire des drames des deux peut être tout
retour c'est un mec avis cailly c6
ouais je pensé à peut-être en faire des
scream en français mais à mes yeux
enfin j'ai pas trop le temps en fait
dole de décès y ait vraiment de faire ça
tous les jours et où donc cette fois
j'ai un peu abandonné je suis un peu
occupé là je suis comme ça en fait le
suivant je suis entraîneur surtout donc
ouais voilà donc mais c'est vrai que
s'il ya un jour je recommence à faire
des scream sur ma propre chaîne
peut-être que je penserais enfers en
france elle savait que ça serait ça
swingue ça serait bien comme ça du coup
du coup vous pourrez vous pourrez au
barça
et c'est vrai ça aux règles pour les
suisses ou belges c'est vrai c'est 5 j
avais pas pensé mais je pense que vu que
vu la cnil a posé la question après avec
les filets 3 pour nos interrogations
je pense que c'était pas vraiment
d'allié n'était pas lui aussi loin
ok donc alors là on aimerait bien voilà
tous anciens c'est pas si simple de
faire
donc j'imagine elle veut peut-être
essayer de faire tour 6-1 après
reprendre avec la table mais surtout
s'il y aura peut-être d'avancer 8 qui
garde le contrôle de la colonne c
ok on peut peut-être qu'ils avaient
faire fou des quatre ici au hall ah
ouais non non c'est pas possible parce
que le kavé va être maître emprise le
coup ouais et qu'elle ait des cartes
bien sûr le pion est en prison que ce le
pouce de ça et c'est ça un peu difficile
maintenant donc là peut-être fou d un
pour empêcher la tour devenir en c2 ou
alors peut-être ignorer ça et faire un
autre ou ok donc apparemment l'aveu ont
peu peur de cette menace
alors si j'ai encore de la condition
montrent la laf là c'est vrai que je
peux pas dire que j'en fais vraiment
hâte mon dernier tournoi s'était
d'ailleurs en juillet 2000 2019
donc il ya quasiment deux ans c'était
mon dernier tournoi fidh mais même en
jeu le coach je compte quand même
reprendre reprendre les tournages
bientôt
du coup aulas est assez simple pour les
blancs même même si au bout il a essayé
de faire des trucs du genre foufou d2
your app est toujours ces deux et la
tour arrive à s'en sortir suivi de peut
être tour à 2 et pour gagner
ouais donc là j'allais dire après la
gaffe mons a pas une gaffe du tout parce
que sur ça on prend je suis ado
relations donc ok content que le 25 le
violon bon c'est difficile de le
défendre
donc là il a bien trouvé le kava singes
c'est difficile de trouver un plan pour
les blancs comme l'a fait changer les
dames et 7 s'en sortir comme ça dam des
deux trous d'un plan
ok donc ce dont elle a réussi à occuper
la case et squillaci est pas mal pour m
alors faut essayer de voir si en même
pas si ça sera difficile parce que le
faux sera toujours en leurs noms
peut-être faire des cadres des rois h2
d'abord alors voir même g3 pas d'autres
ouais j'ai trois celui de roi g2
peut-être et après essayer de faire
quelque chose donc bien sûr j'ai trois
prendre ombrage 3 c'est pas mon prénom
du tout on va se faire cependant on fera
juste 3 2 et après on pourra faire faut
prendre le 5 me adam siens pour protéger
le plus immonde donc ok donc je viens
juste de voir ton commentaire donc
j'imagine que c'était un peu plus tôt et
avec le délai je viens seulement de le
vendre maintenant
donc ouais bon du coup j'imagine via dei
doit y avoir carrément cinq minutes de
délai entre entre le moment où je vois
les commentaires
elle ment ou voix vous voyez mes
réponses
à temps en temps en temps la dame est
notamment est totalement enfermé la
pauvre dame
s'il revient en l1 et qui a fait quelque
4 et la dame et les morts enfin c'est
fou ça va c'est fou ça vient d'arriver
depuis quand pas parce que la gaffe avec
g4 c'est ça le fun oui parce qu'en
jouant g4 elle ouvre le d'un casey 4
assez fou ça bon ben bien jouer
maintenant
alors x h x ou y à mon avis avec a et b
3 qui défend des a alors comment
fonctionne ce soit alors donc je vais te
montrer c'est ça c'est les appariements
et ça c'est le bracket
donc voilà donc là le premier match
c'était entre premier qu'on avait et
bibi ça va donc les bissa a gagné donc
elle arrivera à la prochaine partie mais
mons a pas été sap a été mise à jour
c'est vrai mais du coup ça c'est comme
ça que ça se passe donc l'abacus du
tournoi passent à la ronde suivante
et en ce moment là c'est comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est catherine acompte
valentina donc re retournons à la partie
donc
il ya peut-être des fous j'ai 3 da pour
les cédants d'échangés il faut peut être
pas mal notre être aussi juste up à la
mala on peut prendre le cabanier ça un
peu bizarre quel effet ça heureusement
si elle trouve c'est théorique mais je
connais pas mais j'ai peur on dirait que
c'est super beau mais pour les noirs ça
tu attires des détours 4 la mouette des
cinq ans le suisse a même en s'y
associant ces théories temps et que je
ne connais pas ça
oui voilà super bien expliqué oui oui
oui oui voilà c'est pas vrai par segment
en effet donc au bout d'un moment d'un
certain temps le temps s'écoulera et et
ça serait alors de d'arrêter peu importe
le nom de parti qui aurait été je donc
tout d'abord celle du c'est du simple je
crois que dans un certain nombre de
temps et après ça d'hui 3 + + 2 je crois
et après sept des huit minutes
donc l'arrêt peut-être des dames 15 pour
faire dame g4 et essayer d'attaquer le
roi et aussi de prendre avantage de la
faiblesse mais morel à l'écart et un de
l'autre côté
donc je pense que son idée c'est en
effet la tour en d4 a pressé d'aller
ranger 4 ou alors simplement de défendre
dézinguer de qu'elle veut juste prendre
un éclat tout en un qui a alors le timer
les timer je crois que je n'ai pas
malheureusement il ya un petit bug mais
je peux essayer de voir deux de régler
ça
ok donc là comme vous pouvez voir y
avait tellement haut mais du coup ça ne
marche pas donc je vais essayer de
régler ça et peut-être que peut-être que
ça sera ça sera ma plus tard et vieux
con internet un peu plus juste si j'ai
peut-être mêmes et c'est de revenir sur
zone comme ça vous pouvez parler du mode
aussi je vais essayer peut-être et si ça
marchera pas alors tant moi je pourrais
toujours essayer ça et ça sera fluide à
nous donc j'ai presque envie d'essayer
du coup dites moi dans le chat il doit
tenter bois ces [ __ ] ou pas de tente
et à
là on va danser grand 75 oui c'est ça
voilà voilà
ouais alors ça c'est bizarre que les ce
que l'histoire soit voilà c'est vrai nom
ça devrait
mais ça devrait automatiquement se
remettre mais du coup je savais pas trop
comment faire
oui oui il ya des scores il faut qu'il
soit gaucher photo c'est vrai mais bon
c'est pas ça par la passion envie celle
d'avoir ça va mais will et des sports il
son histoire à gauche
ah oui ça c'est une question assez
compliqué et j'ai pas trop envie de
lancer un débat là-dessus donc on
évitera ce genre de questions ouais donc
donc voilà donc avec nous faudrait pas
que j'essayais zoom
j'ai bien envie de tenter quand même de
voir si parce que j'ai fait une petite
manif est différente sur eux sur les
paramètres de demain instruments tels
que chez orange quelque chose donc
peut-être que si je retourne sur zone
s'alliera c'est pour ça que j'ai envie
de tenter
donc ouais je déconne mais cette tente
est un pote
ouais donc là c'est le parti c'est
gagnant projet blanc je pense je passe
aussi le voir par là il voit dame g6 et
après peut-être même cavalier de cinq
ans fait donc d'un geste fou g7 et
cavaliers 5 c'est super joli ça parce
que si une noire reprennent il ya retour
effet tours 8
quel sagan c'est vraiment super cette
tactique que j'adore ouais donc hélas
hélas bien elle a bien vu qu'il ya un
problème
ok c'est bon j'ai réussi à trouver le
times a en fait comme ça vous pouvez
voir c'est super vous pouvez tout voir
voilà donc vous voyez pas encore mais je
suis en train de faire bientôt vous le
verrez sur votre écran donc je jusqu'aux
pièces à mon insu sera fait ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle
très très bonne nouvelle mais voilà
c'est fait tadam dont il reste en paix
demande de minutes
donc merci de m'avoir dit ça d'ailleurs
parce que sinon j'aurais sûrement pas
pensé à le faire
donc là il reste un peu de monde une
minute alors mais bon là je pense que
c'est clairement mieux pour moi katerina
parce que les bars juste réussir à
prendre un champion et elle a gagné
autant encore encore mieux pour elle du
coup la vue que ouais je pense qu'il y
aura la pause j'imagine le times ah non
il reste 30 secondes
il reste 30 secondes du coup c'est pas
encore fini ouais ils ont le temps de
faire de faire une autre partie
ouais donc là c'est encore une indienne
donc j'imagine que il va se passer des
choses à la note 'aaa' les dames le
timer vient de sonner
ok donc j'imagine que là elle va essayer
de pousser les pions ou alors peut-être
faire affaire qui aurait passé le k
vaillant f2 donc la rouvrir la colonne
c'est ça la main en cas de toux 8 il y
aura cavaliers f2
c'est une bonne question ça du coup je
sais même pas en fait je devrais savoir
mais je ne sais pas en s'additionnant ok
ok ok donc c'est vraiment juste le sport
alors si celle ci c'est le même
coefficient alors c'est un c'est juste
c'est ça assez simple là
donc là je pense que même des coups
comme g4 g5 c'est possible ou alors
comment la jouer comme ça pour ace et
venir en c6 s'avère assez intéressant
même même faire tour ces deux tours
tours c1 c2 show calculant sa tête
o'keeffe même point f hockey
mieux pour me fous des cas ça peut être
intéressant pour les séries mettre la
pression et c'est peut-être de pousser
aux cinq plus tard le 5 sept ans peu
difficile à faire cela tout il y aura
toujours des soucis sur 2,5
bonjour exquise
well you live prendront g6 et alors
peut-être faire des coups comme on sait
il reprend avec un maillot si ça leur
vraiment fort parce que le cahier ça
très bien placé il attaquera aux 6 et 7
juin aura des to process est alors là si
les noirs ne prennent pas voici les
meneurs près n'y aura qu'à et près de 5
le pense et qui frappe vraiment des
grosses menaces sur le fou aussi
donc ouais là il n'ya pas de bonne
défense pour les normes de france
alors là je pense que mon jeu je pense
que c'est surtout une discipline de
travail que les féminines ont pas
forcément comparé aux hommes je pense
que c'est surtout ça la différence et
judit polgar a vraiment bien travaillé
c'est pour ça qu'elle a réussi à le
faire donc je pense que c'est ça la
différence principale aussi décider si
les féminines bosser aussi durement et
aussi avec la avec la même discipline
que les hommes 1
je pense qu'elle allait retirer aussi
mais bon elles le font pas donc c'est
pour ça et aussi vu qu'à man 2 féminine
qu'il faut c'est aussi plus difficile
mais en sorte de trouver les féminines
qui se fait ici sont très sont fortes
mais bien sûr je pense pas qu'on aurait
des qui arriverait au ton niveau de
cagnes de carlson je pense que c'est
juste pas possible parce que le nombre
de films qui joue aux échecs comme paris
au nom de l'homme ça c'est vraiment
difficile de trouver des défis qui est
libre
enfin la fille unique qui va réussir
arrivé à ce niveau là donc voilà donc je
pense que pour ça c'est un peu ça vaut
possible
odong c'est pas utiliser passait pas dû
partir un homme c'est un tournant en
fait c'est le tournoi speechless et
moins donc ça se joue en fait on a on en
est à la rampe 2
donc là peut-être des des cavaliers qui
bouge delebarre pour ensuite poussé à
cette ça fait mal
ouais ouais ses gardes il ya 3 et 3 que
nos différences assez intéressant on
commence par du 3 du sein depuis ce 2 et
après on fait du 3 3 mois + 2 je crois
et après ça dieu c'est du monde donc
c'est cette bonne et j'ai pas vu ça
c'est assez souvent c'est assez
intéressant comprendre ça c'est cool
mais en fait c'est vrai que c'est pas le
manioc
donc là peut-être qu'avec 4 mai sur
catia fou est simple c'est le pam simple
plus un clou saint-cloud cavaliers donc
sans saveur c'est un peu compliqué
ayew coup en fait c'est en floride le
chat bien est ce qu'il ya un moyen de le
désactiver le flou mode comme ça ne sera
plus un peu plus ce drôle si vous pouvez
envoyer des communautés en même temps ce
que bon je pense pas que vous vous
laissez pas mais le tchad donc dont je
suis si je peux des activités se
désactiver si vous savez comment faire
je ça sera c'est assez bien mais bon vu
que je suis pas un pays que je peux le
faire mon pote je suis un peu dans la
pose là ça serait la cause du coût élevé
c'est de la peur
du coup la mort passent presque un
avantage pour les noirs sur la bri a
répété
alors là surtout recaser y aura
peut-être fou ces trois par exemple sur
lequel il bougera des caves et des cinq
savamment pas la teuf slow info est ok
j'ai celle de faire là
[Musique]
en tableau de bord en mode modérateur ok
ok je vais c'est de le faire
désolé j'ai j'ai dirigé fonde toute
petite pause je sais le faire
quand j'allais me touche on en sait
bruit il devrait pas lui mais des vidéos
à chaque fois à ok je désactive smooth
hockey ce lot
ok n'ont a priori c'est maintenant
j'espère
ouais ça fait ok super
bonjour dynamo est donc là les l'a gagné
on a gagné par au time out
ouais donc c'est la pause là je crois
elle a joué la partie mais il a joué le
premier coup mais je pense que cela pose
donc atterrir à la mène 4 4 et demi à
trois ans donc c'est bien on est monté
en des commandes pour elle du coup c'est
la pause là donc a priori vont reprendre
dans d'environ cinq minutes mais oui
c'est de céder une partie assez facile à
ces immeubles
donc du coup c'est la pause alors c'est
quoi vos pronostics alors allez me
parler par nîmes raison
[Musique]
ouais du coup cela pose donc en
attendant je pense que je semais que les
comprimés au cube et je retourne dans sa
lutte donc à tout de suite
[Musique]
ça y est ça repousse donc elle vient de
commencer et elle songe wing karo kann
donc ça c'est le début de la partie dont
cannes plutôt classique mais ça c'est un
peu bizarre qui peut-être a maintenant
certain que c'est normal je venais juste
pas assez tôt je crois que la dame air
et on peut mal parti en d2 mais ça se
trouve c'est théorique donc bon
j'imagine
elle va pouvoir faire ok donc savoir des
larmes s'il va prendre après la russie à
libérer sans fou donc c'est l'heure ok
donc ces cinq donc là les blancs sont
obligés de faire quelque chose donc
j'imagine et va essayer de prendre et
c'est par des chevaux seront donc prises
or si d'emprunt il y aura paix tours 5
mais non tout récent et qu'il peut
prendre dix ans d'un point et d'un
contrat-cadre ses potes donc des
français 5 d'un en france et 5
[Musique]
ok ouais ok là il a pas vous échangez je
pense que c'est une bonne décision de sa
part
monclar et pêcher bien qu'il reste deux
mois le temps une point ça descend assez
vite
vos amis de la vallée premier fois ça me
dérangerait pas personnellement je crois
que c'est assez bien mais je trouve que
ça c'est bien noté surtout que c'est
juste des parties en ligne
ça va vraiment pas si mal
ouais surtout c'est juste fin c'est un
événement si c'est un bel événement
c'est vrai mais c'est pas en revanche a
perdu menton un truc comme ça c'est
juste un an tout rond ça nous
divertissent à un bon tournoi mais bien
sûr c'est pas sympa comme tout bon donc
je trouve parmi la famille là bas il va
ni pas la première se passait mal sans
excès compare pas aux joueurs de foot ou
même les autres rumeurs peut-être mais
pour lui ce genre de chef trouve que ça
va c'est mieux que ce qu'il ya dans la
plupart des autres
alors du coup là je dirais que ses
positions et peut-être même mieux pour
lier pour les normes parce que question
de faire payer 6 pour saper ses deux
pions peut-être aussi attaqué dépasser 8
ou alors invite même ses huit ça peut
être pas mal
ou alors simplement faire un v6 pour
stopper pour stopper toutes les avances
taux plein chez beaucoup donc le raid
sont presque au niveau du temps de
caterina peut-être qu'elle peut jouer
j'allais dire justement j'allais dire
telle qu'elle peut essayer de faire ça
et après faire tour s'est vite
alors mes scores contre des participants
d'alors s'arrête pas et hop à la plupart
d'entre elles j'ai pas vu contre elle
d'ailleurs contre catherine allano je
pense pas avoir joué contre valentina
commandes d'appareils
ouais je pense que j'ai vraiment pas le
banc de rennes à part peut-être une ou
deux mais en généralement je fus mouais
je fais pas les bornes on est dans les
temps voire un peu con qu'il ait joué
contre à la musique jeux que les déjà
battu nadal mise elle m'a battue
stefanova je ne me rappelle pas je crois
pas que j'ai joué contre el conejo emma
pas dessus sinon le reste ça on dit rien
assis corrie au cinéma non je crois que
j'ai déjà fait nul contre l outil mais
en général un pourquoi pourquoi
ouais donc voilà c'est passé pas d'offre
mais mes scores contre contre ces femmes
là je repars sur la ma meilleure perf
alors je en partie langue on parle alors
je sais pas j'ai déjà dû par des grands
maîtres mais mes parents mon parti
précise dans la tête
voyager garde battue je pense 2550 qui
font que ça ma mère père ou un choix
j'ai fait mieux contrer le contrôle de
deux 2006 en amont 30 environ mais voilà
ça ne s'est pas séparé non plus
donc ok donc là il ya quand même un
sacré avantage pour les noirs vu qu'il
ya un plan plus donc peut-être après ça
il peut y avoir des cavaliers quatre
cavaliers avec a minima
ouais j'ai cinq mais il fait pas grand
chose dans les cinq
ouais tête il peut se replacer en effet
quatre dates des quatre aussi
oula le piment h4 qui tombe ça thalmann
donc pas top pour katerina
ouais donc elle a perdu c'était c'est
assez prévisible donc valentina revient
ni au score donc ces quatre partout
donc ghorifa de cette fois google c'est
qu'on a je crois qu'on n'a pas eu ça
encore sa première fois qu'on est
qu'elle ne joue pas le stand-up destin
donne le croient pas ou ne trompe pas ce
que je dis non non en tout cas le but
est clairement on n'a pas vu donc tour
s'est ensuite de la prison de ses cinq
frères pas mal cette dame prend à deux
il ya peut-être fou ces quatre agents
mais du coup tu es prendra it la tour en
pâte ici et sur la prise en a 2 tecla
d'améliorer des petits soucis cette dame
c'est en mai avait essayé de faire fous
ces quatre roues c'est vraiment là pas
mais ça du coup elle l'a elle-même
essaye de mettre la pression sur le sur
le pion mais cette donc peut-être aussi
calé j'ai cinq pour attaquer fou
ah non contre un vide sur ils n'ont
jamais
donc katia ça a l'air de pas être top
tôt pour elle maintenant parce que son
pion mais c'est vrai ça de voir des
prime je pense que les occasions en but
de le sacrifier si elle fait tourbe et
betty voilà c'est vrai des prêts
mentalement il faut c'est fou z4 donc la
tour prends mais ça tu as l'air d'être
assez assez dangereux trop court mais
cette celui de tours points 7 en plus ça
a l'air vraiment vraiment et puis cela
je pars à contrer
peut-être même en décalé g5 dans
certains cas
ces six c'est la menace des bains je
pense que c'est celle-ci ce même série
que si on pousse le pian il traquait
mass effet il y aura peut-être damas 4
mai sur damas cascio raffault b5 montait
qu'on arrivera à tenir ce qu'un même en
le poussant même et un salaire un peu
risqué amelio cola et peut-être pas tant
peut-être prendre et surtout prend à s'y
être essayé de chapelles vous genre en
faisant dames 1 d'un rouge
dames 1 dames belle décide peut-être
ouais ouais elle elle l'a vu d'ailleurs
ouais du coup sûr faut prendre ainsi
atteint 10,6 après à face à gagner là
vous salue bien bas
oui ça fait sa valise je vais bien et
toi ou là alors là aussi trouvé mais il
ya des parties de haut fond se fond dans
cette partie c'est incroyable donc elle
a bien vu l a bien vu ça donc surtout
penser un il ya tout apprendre à 8 et
après il ya déjà dix fois ci s'en fout
et fuite fois ci ça a l'air d'être pas
mal donc passé c'est difficile donc
c'est pour ça qu'elle a pris avec avec
l'auto pour pour essayer de tenir un peu
faut prendre ces 8 il ya toujours ces
sept
et ça vous gagne le faut
ça passe c'est vraiment très bon donc là
bon ouais on dit faut tombe
ok là on se retrouve en finale et je
pense que c'est une assez égal c'est un
matériel égal fourgon cavalli je pense
que le cavalier pas forcément en pire
que le fouillis ouais ça a l'air d'être
assez égal que cavalli voilà où en f3 h4
peut-être qui avait fait entre aussi
dans certains cas votre tête droite 4
alors l'inca y c'est bien qu'ils people
et en dessin kim est mais ça sera ça
sera un peu difficile de passer aussi le
ok donc aller chasser le fou elle
voulait attaquer teckel pas et voulait
le mettre en dessin ok donc peut-être
qu'elle peut y avoir des idées pour
pousser un fossile ces fonds là donc là
j'imagine lafargue est décerné pour
empêcher o'kebap ap donc ouais et peut
pousser h4
sur hk assurerait g5 donc obligés de
bloquer
merci merci ouais je m'y attendais pas
vraiment je pensais que ça serait un peu
plus professionnel que ça mais bon ma
demande du coup du coup je pensais que
j'étais vraiment choqué en fait comme
surtout la première question qui m'a
posé cette ces deux sens était temps
fait bizarre même mais bon le reste de
l'interview se dire bosse donc ça va
donc la tête des h3c instante celui de
sao sénateurs h3 banque du coup ça ne
sert pas à grand chose mais je voulais
juste on reprend péché dégâts légers 4
elle savait que du coup c'est un peu ça
peut être bon je sais faire ça et dans
certains cas on peut aussi revenir on
prendrait en g3 si on attend
ouais mais comme ces liens c'est bien
du coup la l'allier blanc il commença à
prendre l'aventage caterina commence
petit à petit à petit ses six écoles
cahier des 500 stands
ok donc la tête froide enfin m6 donnait
le fin d'année il faut quand le cavalier
après essayer de rentrer en c5 ou alors
même versé 7
je pense que ça va ça c'est ça faire pas
mal prendre là et après fait pas prêt
poussier c7
ça c'est drôle qui demande son âge a
failli refaire pour cette interview loc
du coup là il ya peut-être c'est cette
même si tours 17
il y aura des suites d'un v8 qui à
marveaux la recette pour six tours
bougent leur a peut-être même des dames
25 qui attaquent la tour et le cavalier
pour ce 6 voilà c'est pas mal donc si
tout reprendre bien sûr on reprend et
repris en choeur on peut passer
on peut passer comme ça avec eux le cas
il y aurait 5 après une fois que la
dette française y sont point me rendais
à 12 ou alors même mon père détour d un
si c'est nécessaire on enclave on l'a
tous là le pion à attaquer mais l'on
peut défendre à ces bâtiments
oui comme dame c4 dont kerry des cinq
après on peut faire trouver un accord et
laisser d'être agressive quai
ça lui ira ce nas la menace savent bien
et toi
ouais ça ça a l'air vraiment aux
avantages je pense aux vêtements grâce
surtout à se fiancer êtes il a vraiment
très fort surtout plat qui peut pousser
les pions
juste pour vous
hu est sain il vaut mieux y aura en
échec wittmann en sabre la ola priaulx
et encore mieux je pense mais au lieu de
4,7 est un peu dangereux donc camille h
4 savamment metallica h4 bientôt
apprendre cette eau - s'alarment du coût
et du coup elle perd le qu elles perdent
leur image
du coup la lune or vont prendre sa set
et après faudra faire déneiger qui ne
sera pas ce sera pas très simple faire
ça par exemple sur wii / ou un rouge
on aimerait bien faire des tours prend
1,6 mais je pense pas que sa mort
malheureusement mon qu'elle a bien fait
de changer les dames et essayer de
concrétiser son petit avantage d'être
ici de faire des trucs comme ça et aussi
de ramener le cavalier un peu plus nous
pouvait pas par le plan avec deux mais
c'est pas un gros dossier parce qu'on
pourra pousser b6
peut-être qu'on peut faire cavaillé g6
ou 6 17 km à sap
ouais ouais non maintenant là on veut
pas pousser mais ça demeure heureusement
aussi à gagner c'est simple et du coup
on commence d'abord par kerry c6 et
après elle obligée de faire tour à tour
baisse est sûrement et après sur sa tour
rebours en 8es après le 17 et sur qui
est un gros peut faire tourbe et 5 et je
pense que ça gagne en fait
bessette qui a laissé cinq tours b5 et
suivi de cavalli c6 donc là je pense le
coup pour le stopper oiseaux par les
qualifs cahier 5 dans tous les cas il y
aurait eu tourbe et 5 banques
ça aide pas beaucoup
hall est donc aidé à gagner c'est super
donc là 6 5 en avantage de caterina
hockey continue comme ça on est vraiment
parti sur le monde annoncée du coup
c'est quoi vos pronostics alors nouveau
penser qu'elle va réussir à gagner
quatre catégories ouah ça du coup il
reste à temps je tiens quelle taille ou
high res 22 minutes pour les lycées
après l'on passera directement en bulles
est donc la phase finale sera l'ubs est
donc voilà je le pense il reste un peu
moins d'une heure de jeu en tout parce
que là il y aura lieu il y aura ça et en
plus le bullet anjra ça ça durant plus
longtemps donc je prends sur un peu
moins d'une heure donc c'était avant la
dernière qu'elle allait dernière ligne
droite
donc si caterina continue comme ça ça
devrait aller donc là bon el hadj amine
quoi ils sont pas si mal avec avec voici
ces deux fauves la quille surtout se
fout là qui tape qui tapent des quatre
têtes des deux seins parce qu'ils sont
possibles c'est l'arrivée et changer les
pièces
ça va mettre ça dans ces huit là aussi
prendre m ont calé penser qu'à ça n'aide
pas bonne
très très solide très solide en appel
faut voir ce qui se passera en bullet
parce qu'en général valentina je crois
qu'elle est assez forte en bullet donc
faudra voir fondre avant mais j'espère
qu'avec elle réussira parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle a montré de très bons coups
et la zunie en bullet offre en bullet
man quoi il reste dès lors de deux
mandats à la con du loup encore ella
ella ella vraiment bien bien défendu il
a trouvé des coups des coups incroyables
dont certains n'ont certainement de la
partie qu'on a vu l'adoption alors
disent heureux pourquoi ce qu'elle
perdrait des contres t contre elle ou
moi où tu pense qu'elle va craquer ou
alors pouvoir utiliser ça pour mon
salaire de biens d'allier quand même moi
je pense qu en bullet ça va être serré
ça est difficile parce que valentina est
quand même très très bonnes joueuses de
de beats me semble ou de bulles est dans
le coeur assez joué vite mais on verra
je pense que c'est c'est le c'est dingue
bull est que le winner aura le plus de
chances donc trop d'avoir comme ça ne
passe donc temps que temps que quatre
cas réussir avant vos avantages
l'abandon pendant les 20 qui restent
ça serait top
ok dooku alors ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il y aura ça et après du coup sûr
d'un enfant d'apprendre qu'à v4 sûrement
et qui va attaquer le fou et le pion d1
qui est sinon sur sur la prise d'un
prend des 5
enfin sera prise je prends des 5 alors à
ce moment-là il n'y a plus qu'à les p4
parce que l'on s'était défendue par
l'adam du coup cette fois c'est pour ça
qu'elle a fait car ie7 et maintenant
elle est l attaque le client décide de
fait peuvent aussi personnes
ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
pas c'est pas mauvais mais kalou chute a
raison ben non ouais bonne analyse de la
situation
mon côté deschamps sur des chances mais
il faut qu'il faut qu'une vingtaine
rythme c'est peu dire c'est vrai ah oui
oui ça fait alors où la db4 nord et
bekaert qui avait il y avait foule car
c'est pour ça que c'était ce n'est pas
vraiment possible ou alors fou à 4
encore mieux
bref ou et il faut aider car c'est bien
vu sur fou et 2 bien sûr on prend juste
le cavalier donc droit vous êtes bouger
sûrement et après on peut faire des
dames 6 peut-être pour attaquer le fou
et apprennent un peu on peut aussi
essayer deux mois d'avancé les clans
peut-être mais ça ça va être compliqué
parce qu'il ya toujours le commandeur à
wave impôts ou la la la la
mais cette fois ci ça va être vraiment
vraiment vraiment très compliqué d'aller
pêcher ça donc la même coup comme talent
mais ici ça devrait aller s'attaque lui
cavalli et sa menace pas des trucs du
genre qu'est value trust et surtout bien
sûr deux fois ci c'est toujours menacés
donc d'un mauvais si ça je pense que
c'est bien ou alors dame n'importe où en
est même dame est fier je pense que ça
paraît normal je dis maintenant ça s'est
bien défendue par le fonds vient donc
d'un v6 peut-être simplement pour
défendre ce fou et sur la toile
allez dans les fibres question moi je
savais pas je savais pas je pensais
parce que la peur de me donner des
observateurs là il disait toujours qu'il
était pour katia du coup je pensais que
je pensais que ce n'était pas vraiment
faisait pas vraiment partie du truc
elle est entraînée par bladen blad
lequel de blad way du coup elle et les
deux sont les deux sont vraiment on les
connaît bien alors les deux
donc là oui vous pouvez y aura la prison
en a deux qui va permal celui de cavalli
que 3 ou alors peut-être ça qui est roi
g7 a l'air de bien troublant
abou
elle demande tout l'échiquier foulée
appréciant fouet au camp point des bons
pour les blancs ça c'est un sacré
compliment ce que diouf dia ben dis donc
bayrou est un pronom salaire de marché
pas être menace les avantages donc c'est
weight ya quatre chapeaux avec c'est ce
que je pensais mais je te rassure
est-ce qui fait des scream aussi un
problème de temps en temps on voit que
du coup je suis un peu dans ma grotte je
vais je suis je suis pas trop ça
ok donc là le plus bas est classé mais
ça va vraiment faible tout ça ok donc à
l'accalmie décidé de repartir en arrière
bonne décision je pense entamer 3
salaire normal francs enlevé là la dame
de la couleur et la tour
ouais c'est trois normales aussi pour
empêcher les menaces sur eux sur eux une
b2
il reste plus que 15 ont amplement de 40
donc ça commence à s'accélérer et après
ça passerait aux violettes
ta vraie page et contraindrait el massae
qu'on peut ses adversaires ou là mais du
coup laissé un peu c'est un peu dur
le tour de valentina de massacrer parce
que cette tour pendant ces êtres en pur
on peu dangereuse sur d'un médecin qui
aura sûrement g6 tiendra la dame
donc elle est quasiment obligé de faire
fou que trois mais du coup ça donne une
option mais deux c'est elle c'est pas
très agréable à jouer ça surtout
qu'après le pian c3 aussi va tomber
temps qu'ils passent sur les fonds
bloqués ok ça c'est cool
du coup je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
là mais elle a réussi à bien défendre
même éméchée parce qu'elle a fait un
petit pot pour à ce qu'elle a appris le
bloquer en b2c un problème parce que si
c'était pas vraiment une menace sur d'un
pro b 2 h si ça faisait pas grand chose
donc et le règle moi il aurait
clairement pu faire ça mais yoplait a
perdu dont elle a d'abord eu peur de
haschich ou la fête annuelle et tour
bien ça défendions c'est aux ailes mais
la pop et la passion prend davantage la
situation
dommage pour valentina le coup la menace
fou fou de f 5 son bourreau ce molosse
ouais donc petit à petit ils arrivent à
ceux à se défendre
donc peut-être qu'elle peut faire des
tours e1 peut-être ou alors tour des ans
c'est possible pour essayer d'échanger
des tours
ted g4 aussi que c'est même possible
dans certains cas sa griffe mais pense
que ça peut même marcher
wade en classe et toujours pas
facilement c'est sympa merci à jouer
parce que bien sûr le fou il peut pas
bouger il peut pas les en d4 parce que
là la tour elle sera perdue
donc oui oui c'est pas top
donc peut-être qu'on peut faire des fous
des fous ces deux peut-être pour essayer
d'empêcher la dame de rentrer là et
aussi de way jeudi --quatre c'est bien
ça en bons coups agressifs
donc elle prépare g5 que j'imagine
même en là là j'ai l'impression que le
fou de façon hip hop il peut pas bouger
donc ouais donc peut-être et peuvent
même faire tout fou b6 pour essayer de
mettre encore plus de pression sur le
sur le fou et bien sûr comme on l'a dit
le fou on ne peut pas prendre parce que
la tour sera en l'air
oh mince alors est là elle a gaffé mais
je pense que qui n'a pas dû voir que tu
après tour ces deux ou alors pour s' est
en bas sur tours sien je pense qu'elle a
pas du voir qu'il y avait là prise à ce
super dommage
ouais elle a fait une grosse gaffe l'a
donc sur dame prend b2 tourbe est un
drame c'est qu'elle peut mais moi
prendre de l'oeuf ou un v6 parce que le
travail des fonds à six epr avec le avec
le fou du coup la tour sera perdue ouais
c'était moi justement
attendant d'entendre cette voix vouloir
tombe pas c'est quoi
elle a pas pris la tour elle a pas pris
la tour c est incroyable
si elle prenait à tour été simplement
gate est la patrie à tour bally bang mnr
du coup ces gros avantage pour les bancs
elle est simplement un peu plus c'est
fou ça ah mais attends c'est reparti à
temps contrairement à chaud froid rien
cette partie du coup la lan pense que
c'est quand même un gros avantage du
coup elle peut faire des rois g2
peut-être faire des fois ça aide aussi
n'a du coup la faena fait en peinant à
moi ça en vrai une foule a perdu la
table c'est parti je sens que je vais
avoir des cheveux blancs bah dis donc
ok donc elles ont fait nul pas de son
auteur passons au passé à la première
partie on ne pense plus à la partie
présidence on n'essaye pas d'analysé et
on nous dit cette partie voilà donc la
signaux de grünewald
ok alors ok donc la taille mais les ont
fait exploser mais c'est très normal
dans la green fold de faire de faire des
trucs comme ça
donc là il reste 7 minutes c'est pas
beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup surtout je
pense que ça sera juste une partie après
ça serait ton à moins qu'elle joue super
victimes
mon avis ça sera une seule partie de
glisse et après ça sera l'heure de faire
du business
mon dieu coup
il faut trois à paranormal ouais je
passerais bien sur le fond de le câliner
pas prenable on gagne on gagne quelque
chose donc bien sûr il est choqué les 5
et l'a vraiment jose a eu donc surpris
il faut prendre un bel sims dame
française la pression c'est un peu un
craquage ça ouais donc valentine est en
train de craquer j'ai l'impression parce
que la la il a juste hâte en mai battant
un pouvoir pouvait pas prendre de six à
mettet ce qu'il a fait en cif
pas non c'est moi qui ai fait nantes ok
c'est moi qui fais l'impasse j'ai fait
une fois soigné mais je les fais jouer
ça à la pauvre je me disais ok mais
d'ailleurs et pouvait gagner et si elle
pouvait juste de faire cailler
progressiste et elle pouvait gagner
parce que du coup après la reprise
ça c'est assez enlève mène elle n'a pas
agréé l'a fait elle a fait ça dommage
pour elle vraiment dommage du coup du
puch
il ya peut-être des besoins qui aura
peut-être des db4 aussi mais mon b 4 se
passe pas vraiment recommandé parce que
le fou sera en l'air si si b4 ne ne
contrôle plus fous
du coup niveau taille rire est un peu
moins de cinq minutes nous pousse à
cette partie c'est à ce que ça sera même
pas la largeur de brit
cavaye des quatre îles efforts là je
pense je ch'ti rock ça devrait aller ses
deux pions celle-ci se désaltérant super
fort
voilà du coup un faut prendre aux
attendes il ya peut-être qu'à vivre
quatre faux promis à des cahiers de 4,4
ou là haut
peut-être qu'elle vient juste de gagner
ou alors faut il faut il faut qu'elle
fasse h3 la whey il faut défendre parce
que sur vous croyez qu'elle est peut
être ça gagne parce que ce rouge et
royal est à mes yeux deux mais sagan le
faut ouais donc est la bienvenue
elle a bien fait à chaque fois
[Musique]
le pouce avec dams et 3 qui arrive ça
serait quand même gros avantage pour
aller voir ici
pour nous c'était possible surprise
d'enfants salaires est une super bien
pour les brise
ouais voilà exact exactement wim van
sant avait raison des cassures tireur
pris ce prix les cavaliers de 4l bon du
coup je vois des commentaires ça me
taperais mais là on range les wallons
klotz et 7,7 s'est même possible
j'ai bien envie de faire c'est cette
même maintenant parce que sur la prise
il ya ces huit hockey l'a pas fait pour
ces huit au fronton et non bon il
devrait y avoir des choses à faire sur
cette diagonale
ok j'ai quatre ferries et joué
agressivement sur saddam et 6 donc je
pense que ça serait mieux pour eux ah
ouais c'est fini et page 3 ah oui là
c'est fini donc dam des quatre mêmes sa
menace mat
ah non là il n'y a plus rien à faire sur
dame des 4l peut quasiment bonnes
chaussures à petit ça j'imagine y aura
dix y aura des seules choses qui vont
arriver au même tour c'est cinq awards
est induite encore mieux encore
à quoi que c'est pas si c'est en fait
attendre après ouais ouais c'est pas
clair c'est très clair du coup s'il
trouve ces masses nuls maintenant
ouais je sais pas s'il est je pense que
la sélection a été bien moins en tout
cas ça a l'air d'être assez fluide donc
ouais je sais pas vraiment aux cayes un
bon il n'en décalage aussi à se trouve
attendre s'il retrouve sa femme parce
que je prenne ont dû commencer
c'est juste et en décalage peut-être
parce que j'utilise rim aurait elle a
gagné ouais les blancs gagny hop et donc
à vérifier ya quinze secondes avant le
timer avant que le times of hand que le
que le tyrone mince alors j'ai envie de
parler anglais que le times c'est cool
du coup elle a quand même réussi à
europe 1 va faire une autre partie et
voilà le tagueur time is up
voilà donc face ont même réussi donc je
pense que c'est en tête c'est katrina
qui a vraiment envie de jouer pour la
gagne en amplitude
je sais pas en fait vite c'est la mcc
vous pour laquelle c'est mieux on va
voir ça un bullet laquelle sera la
fabrique ça c'est intéressant
donc là moi je dirais que là le plan se
dote de pousser des cinq plus tard mais
ça va être un peu compliqué d'organiser
ça
peut-être fausse et 4 aussi faire
d'énormes d2 d'un bep 2 pourrait se
défendre ce qu'un médecin et le plomb il
n'est pas vraiment attaqué mon cul monde
donc ça devrait aller
même si la dame a salute ces mêmes même
ça c'est pas vraiment problème dont on
peut même faire ses cinq ans moment ou
alors je suis revenu d eux
mesdames vidéo ça peut être un peu
embêtant parce que dame d2 il ya
peut-être qu'ils allaient prendre des
cartes qu'elle prend et c5
parce que du coup si le cab et hiboux
jorhat au courant des trois vu que la
dame ce rôle à la dame ne peut pas
reprendre par l état à youku bon ça a
l'air d'être un peu mauvais pour les
banques grecques ase dessin qui est
faible
on aimerait bien passer qui a failli là
mais c'est pas possible malheureusement
parce que entre temps le puant des
cartes va tomber
ouais voilà le cavaly d'apparemment case
surtout qu'il peut pas passer par des
deux yade au real et en ces cas pour
taper son a5 ou alors peut-être aller en
décidant b6 mais il peut pas fait il
peut pas aller donc soit il ya toujours
le problème de la case des 4 as donc ça
ça s'est joué donc à peut-être nous fout
il peut aller là où on pas de cavaye
dessin est le fruit palier des 6 ou
alors peut-être même souhait sein du
tout essayé d'échanger
y'a quelqu'un qui a une mauvaise journée
je crois comme un chat
voilà qu'avec à l'étranger 3 mais du
coup je le sais pas exactement à quel
moment c'était donc je pense que c'était
il ya longtemps mais du coup je peux pas
trop revenir en arrière merelle
malheureusement et le décalage le peut
pas avoir les commentaires en direct
au mob est simple c'est peut-être
possible la b5 et après sur la prison va
reprendre et après même peut-être se
créant en plus on battait well you /
dame ces deux il y aura à ce moment là
il y aura qu'à veiller b4 ou du coup il
sera obligé de retourner en c1 et à ce
moment là il y aura peut-être des a4 ou
alors cavaillé bekaert c'est possible
aussi
elle était mineure en tant que telle
elle va du coup il s'est bien trouvé une
carte dans nos cavaliers en b 4 me à ses
ports moi je dirais que quand il ya un
gros avantage pour les noirs ici c'est
vraiment difficile à tenir sa voix est
simplement d'un sait si ça bloque
l'avancée duction et peut-être qu'on
peut faire des faux procès 3 suivi de
caïds et 5 mai elle même même tête fouet
cette celui de faut prendre ce sens
c'est peut-être possible aussi sûr
qu'avec as tu aura peut-être des absents
ou alors tu vas y bouge pour attaquer la
balada
alors le dga je sais pas d'où ça vient
peut-être que parce que je fais sur les
films en même temps et du coup je fais
en même temps sur twitter youtube avec
un petit décalage mais je sais pas je
sais pas c'est un peu bizarre
d'habitude c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive d'ailleurs que je sais que
c'est tellement gros décalage la savoie
a peut-être que je vois je sais pas dans
mes paramètres bobby gaz tels que je
peux faire mon corps si un scoop ça
essaie de le faire un truc salut ça
utilise je sais pas comment dire en
français par contre ce que je veux dire
maintenant que nous avons même pas que
je le dise
j'avais pas se manquer je pense en
anglais à chaque fois je pense en
anglais et du coup j'essaie de traduire
en français
du coup des fois j'ai oublié la
traduction du coup ça donne du coup du
coup mon guy hoquet donc là il nous faut
ces cinq c'est super ayé super
monstrueux
hayek avait b6 est aussi dans certains
cas maintenant après tours 17
après tous ces événements là c'est plus
possible avant parce que la tour 18 va
tomber mais du coup à tour ses uytsel
c'est bien fou aux sept aussi ouais
ouais donc labour aux inventeurs je me
reprenne
bonjour corbion
oh well as gagné autant mongay bunting
donc là le blitz est finie donc c'est
l'heure du bullet donc c'est intéressant
de voir ça ce qui va se passer
ouais donc là il ya la pause mieux pour
mon pause de 5 à 10 minutes je sais pas
exactement combien de temps sait si la
trouve ces moments que ça d'un coup
c'est juste trois minutes que je sais
pas en tout cas à ma du coup je vais
faire je vais faire une petite pause et
je vais être de retour comment les
parties recommenceront donc je vous dis
à tout de suite payante
en attendant j'ai vu je vous mettre la
pub donc voila a tout de suite
[Musique]
ça y est les parties ou en reprise donc
voilà ce qui se passe encore bon c'est
le même genre de pollution à chaque fois
il n'y a rien de vraiment qu'il qui
nouveau de ce côté là mais du coup là en
les deux côtés on va perdre de faux
ouais donc sur dame akata aurait été
très bon mais parce que sur la dame
aurait été enfermés donc c'est bien
qu'elle n'ait pas fait avec elle et
dessert est peut-être qu'il ya cinq a
laissé 4
bon coup pour l'empêcher mais du coup le
cas il va venir par mes six donc câble
et b 8 c'est bizarre ça je me demande ce
qu'elle fait avec caribéen 8
c'est super bizarre avoue bien tout
c'est aussi ça va c'est quand même très
bizarre ce qu'elle veut trop de sens
ouais bah du coup un échange de dames
sarrassat un gros avantage parce que du
coup il va prendre au moins bon et la
paperie mais elle aurait pu prendre et
si on regarde est sûre vous prend il y
avait foule à cette dame français toi
faut première fois c'était sa gaine mais
elle l a pas vu donc voilà si c'est
passé à bâle à vue well as vu un peu en
fait plus tard ok donc ouais donc buntin
avapro mangani cette partie
donc la libellule est c'est un peu plus
vraiment il ya beaucoup plus d'action
qui se passe c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment départ va tout peut arriver
mais là c'est pourquoi elle c'est pour
ça qu'elle se bat toujours parce que
tout peut arriver ambulance mais bon il
y aurait 7 selon donc surtout que
l'adversaire il y ait là 27 secondes
donc ça fait ça avait beaucoup de
différence quand même surtout qu'elle a
une pièce demande
ouais bon apparemment elle est un peu
amer du coup sûr qu'à les prendre mais
5t qu'elle pouvait rentrer revenir mais
à partir il ya des chances qu'ils aient
des chances de toute petite chance pour
ab3 l'a peut-être je vais vite on pourra
prendre trois
elle se bat elle ce pas
donc là la place ça va être compliqué
mais ouais même jeudi bouger les
cavaliers au port
ouais surtout elle va trouver autant de
terrain
à presque à marans il ya aussi indiquent
des rois b2 takkal auraient pu encaisser
de haye peut toujours le faire
d'ailleurs
oui maintenant le roi s'échappe et
j'allais dire d'essayer de faire maths
au roi et comme quoi il arrive on peut
hein ça va se créer des menaces si elle
se trouve elle va réussir à l'arnaqué ça
va être incroyable si elle réussit
oulala ça seront pas réussir si elle
fait fou et de et qu'elle arrive à
pousser à non banon du moulin cette
approche mais youku la scène ça n'a pas
vraiment être possible quoique fois que
tout peut arriver encore women of l'on
méconnaît la bonne technique pour gagner
donc c'est pas possible
après s'être ou en droit le 7 c'est fini
- bonne partie de la part de valentine
a du coup bah du coup j'ai loupé les
commentaires parce que du coup je
regarde avec mon portable mais oui mais
je n'ai pas deux j'ai pas de nouveau à
de nouveaux commentaires du coup ils
vendent d'amis
bah du coup désolé si j'ai si j'ai
ignoré vos commentaires
voilà peut-être faire des tours si on
perdait à trois aussi chasser le faut on
aimerait bien faire ex 3 peut-être
meilleure équipe en g3 donc pas trop
faisable peut-être même d'un des trois
échanges et les dames ça peut se faire
ouais je m'y attendais en fait que
ballantyne asseoir ouais parce que enfin
tel schéma j'ai juste l'impression que
c'est une super bonne joueuse de de
speech est faste de jeu très très rapide
donc je sais pas d'où je tiens cette
information d'ailleurs mais je sais pas
moi je le pensais ça dans mon coeur
on ne dirait qu'en fait elle et elle est
là la légendaire est correct
ouais le budget c'est le vrai jeu est du
coup c'est les parties variables à
double tranchant c'est faux ce qui se
passe naya le curage 4 qui en l'air le
pion 6,6 et en l'air aussi pour les
points noirs à sefrou ça ce qui se passe
donc la faire des commentaires sur le
but c'est pas très facilement il ya des
pièces qu'ils veulent à chaque où aller
mais soudain je pense que là l'avantagé
pour les blancs gros avantage je dirais
même si elle arrive à faire des tours
c'est celle peut-être même juste poussé
le cube et ça devrait être suffisant
ouais et elle a gagné
donc là il reste qu en paye moins de 16
minutes un peu monde c'est donc ça
commence à aller très vite
donc tout peut arriver on c'est bon
c'est vraiment pas qu'ils veulent qui va
gagner c'est vraiment pas ainsi mais je
pense je dirais plutôt valentina parce
que parce que c'est vrai qu'il est le
jouet vraiment bien en partir courte
mais ouais surtout que la dernière elle
a gagné donc et celle d'avant si elle a
gagné je crois donc pas
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien vous regardez
le score en bus est follement j'ai pas
vraiment en santé il s'est passé quoi en
bullet pour nous dans l'ailé soit en
bullet c'était quoi parce que du coup du
coup je ne veux pas savoir si vous aviez
si vous vous en rappelez alors ouais il
faut croire schiste peut être pour alors
déroulé et wise as vraiment surprise aux
astros annoncée du coup on peut
peut-être faire
ouais ouais ok ok ouais ouais du coup
pour prendre le pion à c'est normal
ouais c'est vrai ça un temps de bon là
lequel il aimerait bien aller en 24 mai
il y aura le fou qui va prendre à chaque
fois donc
d'ailleurs c'est le seul moyen pour les
noirs de sauver parce que sinon il n'y
avait qu'à aider 62.4 c'est que ça se
tente
le bureau il va bientôt être un
véritable attaf harrison maloney sinon
tu appareils et combien près du coin il
ya des grands choses que tu aurais coutu
garneau paris ah non mais tu es tu m'a
juste dit à moi je me rappelle ok tu
avais juste dire moi oui saurait
s'arrêter manque que tu cultives que tu
étais parier jean roy miller mille
bonnes mais non du coup c'était juste
quand j'ai demandé cette somme de 1 pour
valentine en défense
ok ouais ouais donc c'était ça le score
pour le monde en bullet et doit bord
deux ans après +1 pour valentina
auxquels on fait donc tu as bien raison
mona il se passe quoi là
donc je dirais presque que maintenant ça
avantage noir parce que ouais mais non
mais c'est chaud je pense qu'elle peut
pas arriver à mettre son voile a paru
bien sûr le purgatoire va perdre à moi
non mais j'y comprends rien à ce qui se
passe ouais donc là il va gagner un
créneau
je pense pas c'est assez facilement wen
assez facilement parce que l'aller c'est
pas possible pour le roi de gagner en
entier pions parce qu'à chaque fois il a
le pion il va tomber et après sur food
et 4 le fou ne peut pas stopper depuis
en même temps
donc caterina mène pour le mans
donc ça c'est l'ouverture
cg c'est un peu bizarre si une espèce de
cadalen japon ou alors un système de
landreau mais fait mais c'est un peu une
structure de sabdo froid mais bon avec
l'afrique le fourrage et 2 c'est pas
très normal
surtout qu'il ya même pas le fort des
gones n'ont pas voir ça ressemble enfin
à rien que je connais
et donc là peut-être h 5 h 4 ouais donc
à la mairie essaie d'empêcher ça ok
thomas mich les quatre là même nom mais
j'ai 80 km et 5 à ses tarifs pour les
blancs ça c'est terrible ne sais pas
c'est quoi régis bas ces gaulois mais
parce qu'elle a enfin su défendre ce
pion elle aurait dû doubler les tours au
lieu de se focaliser sur ce h 4 h 5 que
ça avait pas grand chose à ce moment là
ça allait mais il aurait elle eu je
pense qu'elle aurait juste dû faire
tourner autour des 3 et tournant pour
essayer d'oublier tour c'est l'astuce
pouces ils sont payants laférois jésus
mais ça servait à rien du coup elle
s'est retrouvée superman à super dommage
ça vraiment dommage
c'est un froid parce qu'elle a fait bon
bah du coup elle a le pion de tombes
système de paris à qui celles améliorer
l' inverse sur un meilleur et du sitcen
novembre ouais ok mais continue elle a
quand même bon pièces de mon point donc
à l'abandonner
donc c'est très serré 9 et demi par tôt
et il reste en paix une grande détresse
donc tout peut vraiment tout peut
arriver
ok donc comme d'hab les blancs veut
pousser ces cinq les noirs me pousser de
ce côté là et c'est une ouverture assez
bien c'est un bon chemin en bullet parce
que c'est vraiment un double tranchant
tout peut arriver là donc erkan n'ai pas
aimé là c'est parce qu'il ya toujours
flash 4 donc vous le fou n'est pas
perdue donc f3 bien sûr pour chasser les
pour cacher il s'en fout ouais bien vu
et du coup maintenant elle menace de
pousser c'est simple
ouais ça va être une belle gaz propose
ici de l'utiliser comme ces deux c'est
bien vu ouais sur gk tu auras des
cavaliers c'est ça peut être
bref prendre aussi saignant qu'à essayer
de salir notre d'être super nombreux f3
c'est pas une menace je pense parce
qu'on arrivera juste apprendre à 8 le
pinceau sur f3 à est sûre ça y est même
fou b6 mais je pense on peut juste
prendre la turque d'ailleurs mais auquel
a fait faux b6 donc c'est assez logique
çà çà çà çà laisse pas de possibilité
pour les morts
où l'ol s'est sacrifié ouais elle a bien
défendu pensée ou l'autre mais elle
aurait pu juste pendant tout en fait
mais frau l'a pas juste prendre puis la
tour et après fait foi fo f3 après bon
bah mince alors pour elle ouais donc là
bas c'est pas moi c'est vraiment
chaotique sept pays dont je n'ai
absolument pas si spot aucune idée donc
ouais donc là les noirs attaque le pion
et peut passer en eux un deux roues là
ça va vite qu'elle est simple peut-être
ok non répéter les coups d'état qu'elle
cherche la nulle allait essayer de
passer elle n'arrive pas et veut venir
en c3 je pense le pion il est important
ouais là ça va être les gens qui
m'envient ni quoi que je pense
clairement
oh non mais c'est fou qui va se passer
mais il est justement du coup elle est
juste moitié yaya touré h1n1 et au mes
qui s'est passé c'est fou ça non mais si
elle faisait juste là où lui 2 au lieu
de faire de la dame si elle faisait
juste trois ponts là à ce moment là s'il
faisait juste d'apprendre d'un projet de
fonds était jusqu'à nantes et menacé de
prendre le pool de la tour était jeudi à
lyon sur f2 et le rhône avec la dame
mais elle a donné le dogme c'est flou
c'est là de l'un des maîtres traumat
bailly donc vas-y donc au québec on
dirait qu'elles ont fait une petite
pause c'est bizarre tu as l on fait une
pause alors que au times
il reste 5 minutes bah je sais pas ce
que ça veut dire du coup je sais pas ce
que ça veut dire du coup je vais
peut-être croisé sur une note yann faut
voir ce qui se passe c'est à trouville
on arrive et on définir je regardais
quand même qui se passe je vais sur la
chaîne principale pour aller boire un
peu
oh
ouais mais matt nix on n'est pas si loin
pour l'heure pour regarder sur l'ordi
donc bon je peux pas nos as a repris
hockey enfin sa reprise ok super âge
mais je suis permis parce que c'était
pas censés arrêter tout de suite j'ai
pas ce qui arrive et qui est donc alors
by c10 a dit sa dispo et demi comme neuf
et demi en la faveur de caterina c'est
bien
ouais non c'est incroyable ce qu'elle
avait un club cela par l'amont présente
moi elle a juste craquer
du coup là il ya des fous des trois
jaillir salaires a su faire revient pour
une offre un format long des 5 aussi
avoir des soucis
quelle quelle idée 3 et call ouais ok
non plus maintenant
c'est pas passé le premier banc
et il reste 3 minutes 30 minutes et 40
secondes
aulas ça est fini va bien bientôt mais
du coup si quartier rien à perdre cette
partie
le score sera égale donc j'ai pas
exactement ça se passe comment le le
tie-break en fait je devrais savoir mais
du coup je ne sais pas vous mais est ce
si la trouve y en a marre guaino ou
alors il continue à faire des bulles est
ce que j'imagine qu'elle ne serait pas
si c'est le score égal ça sera la
première qui m'aurait qui m'a
franchement tu ne sais pas où la n va et
vient de perdre sa dame ouais donc que
valentina va clairement gagné cette
partie bien bien je pense il n'y a pas
une bonne chose
il n'y a pas de grandes chances pour
être signé katerina ici
et ba et ba faire flouer f2 au prochain
we can ok cette partie basse et des
dommages pour katerina mais on savait
qu'on savait qu'elle allait perdre vu la
position qu'il y avait elle s'est bien
battue
donc c'était fini depuis longtemps
il reste plus que 2 min bah dis donc je
pense qu'il y aura tant pour deux
parties maximum ça sera tout
donc là peut-être vers 10 h 3o prend 3
ouais c'est ok on attaque la dame qui
ont des quatre hauts gradés de gros
soucis ont fait pas gaffe ou la même
vous prendrez trois là c'est peut-être
possible mais d'avoir mettre leurs mains
sur tes bien sûr c'est plus important du
coup là les banques sont obligées de
cesser de défense a commis peuvent
peut-être fou séance est obligatoire on
est fou et 3 mais du coup il y aura
quand même tout retour des 8
allez ok ok ok avec du blé du mort
subite ok ok on assez logique
du coup on va peut-être y arriver il
reste 54 secondes
donc elles ont peut-être le temps de
finir cette partie d'un commencer une
autre dans ce cas là il ya de grandes
chances que le match ne soit de nouveau
égal même après ce résultat là si leur
joie encore une partie ça sera assez
globe au moins se fait romance ah ça
c'est horrible
yaka idée si ce qui arrive en plus aussi
horrible pour le bon donc
katerina bien pris sa revanche la ouais
c était comme au tennis
comment qu'on a pendant quarante 40
partout après celui qui gagne c'est ça
le favori est ce pareil c'est celui qui
a pas la pression et le temps est écoulé
le temps est écoulé du coup caterino va
sûrement gagner cette partie est du coup
elle va gagner
là j'imagine aux états unis pas super
bas du cou et la russie et le temps bien
c'est bien ségolène à temps pour s en
europe elles ont replongé à temps c'est
bizarre tu es parce que le losc aurait
et séminaires c'est peut-être pour ça a
ok c'est parce que le score est
similaire
when you couvre du coup évoqué c'est
logique c'est logique droite
ah ok donc donc ils viennent d'arrêter
la partie donc j'imagine qu'en fait ils
ont bien arrêter le match vu que katrina
est favorite et que mais c'est je pense
que c'est juste une erreur de manif qui
commençait à jouer au la peau ballantyne
ans il a eu des faux espoirs c'est moche
pour elle elle a eu des faux espoirs bon
bah du coup et du coup c'est fini alors
on dire parce qu'ils ont arrêté la
partie ça va être une belle du coup
c'est super nes et super mouche pour
elle lkk commencé en juillet partie
super motivés et tout mais après un
hoquet mumbai du coup katerina l'anneau
et l'a vaincu zh donc voilà donc là je
mets juste les
mais oui et les résultats donc voilà et
là on n'a pas encore les lire
il y a des scores exacts mais voilà ça
c'est ça c'était ça les appariements
donc demain je pense ou alors deux
prochains jours que ça seras tu sais pas
exactement quel sera le quel sera le
planning mais le prochain match sera
entre kosteniuk et drones ovalie donc ça
sera un match aussi très intéressant
donc là il ya beaucoup de très fort
douloureuse donc à chaque mois tu seras
ça vraiment vraiment qu'un spectacle
donc ça va être super cool de voir ça
donc ça sera je pense que c'est ça sera
bientôt je sais pas exactement quand
bart ils ont annulé en fait un grand
match qui était censé être le samedi
donc qui était censé être le vendredi
pardon donc je sais par exemple peut
être que demain il y en aura un autre
match
faudra que le voit donc oui voila voila
donc c'est fini c'est fini
donc bon bah merci à tous d'avoir
regardé j'espère que j'espère c'était
cool j'espère que ça vous a bien diverti
ouais donc je serai peut-être de retour
pour commenter les matchs